hello and welcome to see your video glue
video luckily a corner haven't played
for a long time it's a very regular
opponent though 11 wins one loss for
drawers so what do we get let's do
something else now let's not people and
I want to play groom felt but d5 is a
silly primo after 93 yeah the group felt
really not an opening that I know well
or hot or anything else okay here i
think take and you take on c4 i guess at
least them normal looking maybe this
okay
can you do this and give up this poor
now for 9 p-6 adult I don't know
efore might be a move yeah the green
felt is something where I'm basically
making up things as I go along 95 yeah
this this this looks a bit strange huh
55 e for Bishop c6 that looks dangerous
now but what else I mean can I go
somewhere else probably not maybeee for
h6 is a movie for age six sticks but
that seems kind of playable Knight f3
back okay that's not a big deal if he
goes back Bishop takes and now Knight b6
was my idea and trying to get the fire
which should get to get to equal
material at least you can take on c4 now
this might be might be a big issue
okay let's say i'll take their queen to
be five i can actually place the six
right c6 takes 96 it's not working so i
can go see 60 mm jack TX 96mm should
keep the peace and so it has to check
with the Queen and now I can take with
the Queen Oh at the pawn but with the
Queen looks good it's equal material and
at the end his see pawn will be somewhat
weak and I'm attacking g25 so he has to
take okc pawn is slightly weak it's not
a big deal but I'm happy here with this
position maybe i can actually not
prevent him from that not so easy to get
it moving he also has to vary a bit
about his age porn so cannot easily move
this rook for example okay he wants to
go a fire
hmm Tim I'd really like to answer a 5
with b5 that doesn't seem possible
though yeah only with somewhat unnatural
move like this but other otherwise I
don't see how I'm don't see how I'm
playing for something here
a 5 p-5 a 6 is interesting
and I put can be slightly risky
a six is actually trapping the rook in
some cases ok not ideal really not
now it's got got enough activity here to
be okay for sure yeah I probably applied
something wrong there I think I should
get a slight edge with the week see porn
structurally weeks upon but that never
got God relevant here of course as we
see
angling for Bishop d8 and then a six
can't that I don't mind
a 65 is the idea
but should be five was a bit of a temper
loss
and now my ideas bishops is seven
possibly trade and then still play on
the C file I wonder you should probably
try some mage 4g for stuff not sure if
he gets it in but okay jack and east
year I know what to do have to take it
look see one may be coming by King isn't
a slight issue here all right this is
this should be okay ready it doesn't
have a good square for the king this is
the thing okay how to take now I think
with the rook to have king d 6 check d5
checking Disick's check is good for me
it's now my pawn structure is better
check check
check
yeah it's good now the deep on is weak
and a pawn this week it's a very good
position so do we trade i think i'll
start with this
check so probably look at the a porn
threaten hook see one made time morning
the deep ones just stays week fight
resides hmm interesting quite
interesting the opening as I said it was
all paid up during the game those motifs
I kind of known yeah it's interesting if
he just takes and then here it's a good
structure flight but ship t5 is coming
maybe that's what he has to do I really
don't know ok and here i think it was
technically ok probably it's more
ambitious to move the night again and I
can move it back and something like
listen this may be
or here engine Gibson gives it a round
equal don't know yeah this now and I
think chance is the right way to do it
and now Queen takes I mean here this
looks a bit more comfortable for black
because of that parlance III but maybe I
never get anywhere that's really
possible b6 King here and King be 7 a-4
that's a debatable move but I didn't I
really didn't want to see if a five
coming here it's interesting that the
engine wants to play me five now which I
don't really just this step bad doesn't
look bad okay would be eight I didn't
want to I wanted to have be five if he
calls a five here can maybe also take
this this I think this should be even a
road should be about equal i think and
starting with this he caught he got
himself into a slight slight issues
there and I think maybe in Seattle and
it's somewhere around here see for as a
mistake okay I thought that this already
should be quite good the computer gives
this I was thinking Bishop c7 here just
to trade stuff but the engine wants to
keep it on the board but even this is
supposed to be equal according to the
computer yeah maybe it is I was thinking
that still those points could be could
be a target like group here here here
maybe it's not happening age for g4s is
the counter play a very serious one okay
it's probably equal back for a long time
but here is his verse and after d5
chest losing check yeah now now they're
really just to be phones and no
particular counterplay down okay i hope
you enjoyed the video thanks for
watching